How's it going?
Stephen with Kiwibox.com.
We're up in Island Def Jam Records in New York City where I'm hanging out with Utada.
How are you today?
I'm doing very well, thank you.
How are you?
I'm doing good.
So, your English breakout album is about to come out.
How excited are you to have it out there?
I've been getting a really good response from everyone who's heard it so far.
I've just begun doing all these interviews, and now I'm really like,...
..."When is it going to end?"
Well, I listened to the single "Come Back to Me" and surprisingly,...
...you seem to go with a more club-friendly, up-tempo kind of song.
You went with more of a "ballady" song.
What was the decision behind that?
The whole song, the words and the singing, it sort of enters you naturally.
It comes into you easily.
That was the opinion and so it should be good as the first single.
You know what, honestly, I think the music scene is lacking a bit of,...
...what's the term, like...
Pizzazz?
Pizzazz, yes.
Maybe that's why it seems like a good time for these foreign forces to invade.
Hi, this is Utada; you're watching Kiwibox.
Very cute, by the way.